Sabine Belt the actors have been cast
and each one is saying I've got nothing
to wear for every single costume you see
in a movie there are a whole just the
whole range of decisions the costume
designer has to make color do bright
ones camouflage a dark soul fabric they
do get better as a girl moves up in the
world don't they cut how does the fit of
a suit reflect a character who doesn't
care much how his suit fits style a
story that spans seven decades requires
a complete change of style every 20
minutes just to keep up with itself
authenticity how do you marshal the
research and resources to depict the
full spectrum of Australian society
seventy years after the fact and the
nominees for costume design are
Revolutionary Road costume designed by
Albert Walski the Duchesse costume
design by Michael O'Connor milk costume
design by Danny Glicker
The Curious Case of Benjamin Button
costume design by Jacqueline West
Australia costume design by Katherine
Martin
- the Duchess Michael O'Connor
there's unbelievable absolutely
unbelievable
before I forget I must thank Rachel
Portman for that music in the Duchess
that wasn't the music but music is
fantastic in that film I'm going to
thank parrot Vantage and passe for
promoting the work in this film I think
they did a great job showcasing the film
my crew
I'd like to fight some individuals
police gordon Harmer and a cot the RAM
plaques masquerade aunty Brooke Sarah to
IB I'd also like to thank my agent
Michelle Arnold who is a lovely lady she
got me the interview with these people
and Gabi tanner saul dibb and michael
kuhn stuck their neck out to get me this
job I apparently was the risk and I
think it's paid off yeah
so I'm glad about that and most
importantly I'd like to thank the cast
because you know working with such a
great cast everyone was with me so
quickly Dominic Cooper Hayley Atwell
Charlotte Rampling
ray Fiennes and Keira Knightley you are
one classy lady thank you so much